mesdames et messieurs
chers auditoire du teg fixe bambeto
bonsoir
je vais commencer mon intervention
par une petite histoire
que j'ai vécu
en 2018
alors stagiaire au service des impôts
d'édiction
j'ai fait connaissance d'un jeune
clq lieux et des mandats un jour
ses coûts ou habitue
je lui dis à bambéto
étonné
je gêne mais d'émana automatiquement
bambéto élus du oui
il me dit bambeto 5 ou n'est pas fait
c'est un endroit de délinquants
et éparpillé
et le réflexe
lui poser une seule question
pour m
ou habitue
à lembeye me répondit-il
je dois vous dire
à ce moment précis
c'était entre la confusion et la
désolation
mais paradoxalement
connaissait le quartier résidentiel de
lembeye
je comprenais parfaitement sa réaction
donc j'ai décidé de me taire
comme le dirait une parole de sagesse
là où l'ignorance cri avec arrogance
le silence enseigne avec élégance
bambeto
bambeto et tu réellement
ce que les gens disent de lui
pouvons-nous miser sur l'avenir des
banques béto
quel avenir où la jeune génération et
cette partie de la capitale communément
appelée axes de la démocratie
vous trouverez les réponses à toutes ces
questions tout à l'air
mesdames et messieurs
en effet
la kz1 dans like a baby
a longtemps été le théâtre et plusieurs
événements pour eux est malheureux et ça
vous le savez bien les manifestations
politiques les mort d'homme les
manipulations politiciennes
certains même le qualifier dax dit mal
cette partie de la capitale
en dépit du dynamisme des arènes s
est laissé pour compte
et cela est marquée par une absence
totale une absence notoire les
infrastructures sociales de base
notamment l'éducation à travers les
écoles publiques
et amenant la jusqu'à kabélé vous avez
pis d'essence
de voir
les agents des forces de défense et de
sécurité
que d'écoles publiques ou des lycées
publics
sur cette partie de la capitale
les alarmes et rient jaune nouri
puisque deux buts au public
bref je pouvais passer plus que la zone
est à vous citer les côtés obscurs de
nos quartiers
les heureusement ce n'est pas la partie
la plus importante des monnaies
l'invasion
aujourd'hui
j'aime ça y est investi des visions et
des propositions concrètes
dans ce but nous a libérés la partie
tout est tout à leur
bambeto puisque c'est de lui qu'il
s'agit réellement
l'état
en appliquant les principes de bonne
gouvernance tout en impliquant les
communautés à la base
l'avenir des milieux d une serre à
assurer
l'état
doit s'investir dans la création
les écoles publiques celles que nous
appelons communément les afriques of
nelson mandela ne disait il pas que
l'éducation
et la puissante qu'on puisse utiliser
pour changer le monde
en outre la création des centres de
loisirs les airs 2e comme ça existe
partout ailleurs
le terrain de football les terrains de
basketball
pour les hits et qui sait si
mais combinaison avec moi
qu'il est allé peut pas tout faire
raison pour laquelle si l' axe le jul
s'organise s impliquent dans les projets
de développement locaux
nous par exemple à bambéto
nous avons eu l'idée de créer le entre
la vision commune guinée jusqu'aux
indienne
cette ong a
pour objectif général l'entrepreneuriat
jeu
elle a aussi des objectifs spécifiques
bien évidemment quelques et la
protection de l'environnement la lutte
contre l'immigration irrégulière
l'éducation en passe
et je dois vous dire car 2019 2020 nous
avons participé à beaucoup d'activités
en compte nous avons participé à la
sensibilisation si le respect des
mesures barrières
nous avons participé à la distribution
des masques
nous avons participé aurait boisement de
la forêt et kakimbo ça c'était en 2026
intéressant et ça aussi c'est ça l'idée
passage parce que ces lignes des
initiales initiatives des jeunes de
l'acte qui a eu l'idée de mettre en
parce qu'ils ont cette initiative qu'on
appelle donc illégales c'est une
initiative qui consiste à planter hénart
à l'occasion de la fête de tabaski
donc nous avons participé à la première
édition et à la deuxième édition
ce collègue allemand qu'un jeune de
bambeto bon disons qu'un jeune vieux
et brahms un coût connu sous le nom de
saya
jeu jeunes qui pas sa bonne foi avec ses
maigres - a pu débuter a pu mettre en
place un orphelinat
et cet orphelinat
à redonner le sourire à plus d un quart
john wall et
la quasi-totalité dalle et son talent
mais aussi de faire les activités et de
métier de leur joie
aujourd'hui ce jeune
est en train de bénéficier si on peut le
dire ainsi levé l'orphelinat est en
train de bénéficier c'est l'aide aux
enfants déshérités est en train de
bénéficier du soutien les personnes de
bonne volonté et des ong
mesdames et messieurs chers territoire
du tedx bambeto
la meilleure manière les aider c'est
d'aider les autres
je reste convaincu
qu'on peut être de lax et réussir sa vie
mais pour cela il faudrait que chacun a
sa part
il faudrait que chacun fasse sa part
même si les manifestations politiques
les temps sur les remous et à l'autre on
fait croire à une minorité qui est l'axé
en train de se battre pour un politicien
force est de constater qu'en réalité la
kz n'ai vu qu'un changement significatif
une envie de changement ils datent pas
d'aujourd'hui mais d'il ya une vingtaine
d'années en définitive
pour assurer
le futur et la jeune génération qu'ils
représentent ici
il faudrait une implication effective
des citoyens d'une part et
gouvernementales votre part
c'est pourquoi
le jeu va s'impliquer
quant aux gouvernants ils doivent
travailler d'arrache-pied
pour enfin mettre les infrastructures
dignes de nos
cartes à la jeunesse
[Musique]
quant à la jeunesse dudit bien elle doit
bien évidemment opté pour l'alternance
ya sociale
car l'entrepreneuriat social pourra
résoudre des problèmes fondamental
le chômage et les conflits
le dire insister là-dessus et ma façon
de faire ma part
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]